In this lecture,
we will concentrate
on the study of Markov
chains in the long run,
and study under what
conditions a Markov chain
exhibits steady-state behavior,
and under what conditions
such steady-state
behavior is independent
of the initial starting state.
More precisely, we will look
at long-term state occupancy
behavior-- that is, in the
n-step transition probabilities
when n is large.
So assume that we have a
Markov chain which is initially
in a given state i, and
consider the probability
that the chain is in a specific
state j after n transitions.
Question-- does that probability
converge to some constant
when n goes to infinity?
And if this is the case-- second
question-- can this constant be
independent of the
initial state i?
We will see that for
nice Markov chains,
the answers to both
questions will be yes.
How to characterize
nice Markov chains?
We will use several new
concepts, one dealing
with a Markov chain
being aperiodic or not,
and the other with the
notion of recurrent classes.
Without going into
details now, let
us simply mention
that we will show
that the existence
of convergence
will be tied to having an
aperiodic Markov chain.
And in case we have
convergence, the independence
from the initial
state will be tied
to having a single
recurrent class.
We will end this lecture
by looking in detail
at the special and important
class of Markov chains usually
known as birth-death processes.